hey everyone I'm Ilana and welcome to my
channel what today we are talking about
no men's skies next update for anyone
who doesn't know that's the name of the
update which came out earlier this week
it's not the next update it's very
confusing before we get into what I do
and don't like about the game in 2018
that is I thought it was important to
give some personal context to my history
with this game as a game that that
launched in a lot of controversy in
something that I think will be
remembered in the video game industry
pretty much forever so if you didn't
know before the game came out two years
ago there was a ton of hype surrounding
it but I did not buy into that hype he
is what I said I've said it before when
I'm really skeptical about no man's sky
I feel like everything that we've seen
looks very similar and I don't care
about how big the thing is if nothing is
interesting people will very angry at me
this one guy called me blank and said I
should go play goat simulator instead
for whatever reason but the game came
out and I felt pretty much the exact
same way that I had before it came out
it didn't grab me I didn't feel like
that was enough to do the planets I
encountered what varied enough it just
didn't or couldn't hook me I don't know
a lot of other people felt that way so I
stopped playing it and I didn't play the
Atlas update so this video is angled at
people who either played very little on
launch because they didn't like it or
couldn't get into it or haven't played
it at all so first things first I'm just
gonna come out and say if this game or
launching as it is now in 2018 I would
nominate it for game of the year I don't
like it more than I like God of War I
doubt that I'll like it more than I'm
gonna like Red Dead 2 or even spider-man
but I feel like I like it enough that it
should be in the top 10 just out of
nowhere very unexpectedly I kind of love
no man's sky I will admit my love is
somewhat specific to survival mode
though I would recommend that people
play normal mode first to explain those
to normal mode is described as a chill
exploration experience and it's the mode
that no man's sky started out with you
land on a planet with no recollection of
how you got there even though your ship
seems to recognize you and a toss with
scouring that plant to look for
resources to fix your ship so you can
take off into the stars following a
series of mysterious messages that are
guiding you somewhere the storyline is
interesting enough and worth pursuing
and it's really cool that you can pursue
it in
you play with other people doing it at
the same time but I've largely been
creating my own stories in a way that I
feel is similar to Minecraft Survival
mode follows that same basic concept
just without the chill
so survival mode gives you limited
resources increased hazards and stronger
more aggressive enemies even finding
your ship after you first spawn is hard
you can't just walk there because the
environmental hazards will on most
planets quickly kill you so you have to
immediately figure out how to and what
to mine before you get going it feels
very much like a traditional survival
game and while at least on your first
planet I don't think it innovates hugely
on that genre but I get a feeling from
no man's sky that I don't think I've
ever felt before that is of genuine
space exploration and I really think the
new third-person mode helped me with
that I played almost entirely in
third-person though you can play in
first-person if you want to the first
planet I set foot on was harsh and I
completely believe complaints that if
you spawn on a bad planet there's a
chance that it'll feel impossible for
you to survive and that is a little
unfair but the thing that gets me is
that it feels real yes if I were to
explore outer space I could come across
a planet that is so incompatible with
human life and simply doesn't contain
the resources needed for survival and I
love that about it I want to liken it to
moments in the legend is all the breath
of the wild but on a universal scale
there are some things that you'll come
across that are absolutely amazing so
much so that I don't even want to tell
you what they are on a related note
don't read the patch notes but you might
be flying a ship and notice a planet
comprised of interesting colors you get
closer and you start noticing
interesting patterns on the ground you
get closer to those and realize there's
a giant crashed ship with a bunch of
unopened cago take a look at that cargo
and it needs some mind and door repairs
to be opened you figure out how to do it
you open it and there's something inside
of there that you've never seen before
bits worth thousands of units if you
sell it on a space station but since the
cargo hull was broken it also leaks a
ton of radiation which you want
expecting and you immediately have to
run away maybe as you're running away
you come across an alien artifact that
teaches you a single word of the
language of the gek an alien race you've
met before but never been able to
communicate with now you're learning
about races and their languages on top
of everything else and moments like this
commonly exist in
man sky now on top of hugely improved
terrain generation that makes most
planets really beautiful and
consistently interesting and it just
keeps up that sense of discovery through
every facet of the game and it is
multifaceted now to my second planet was
compared to the first heavenly it was
colorful then we know environmental
hazards except for the occasional toxic
cave and sentinels that would kill me if
they managed to scan me something that I
will admit is mightily annoying because
every large planet seems to have
aggressive sentinels but I digress lack
of environmental hazards meant I didn't
have to worry about hazard support so I
made this my first mining plant because
it was so full of resources I built up
an inventory of oxygen life-support
packs ion batteries sodium all the
things I would need if I encountered
another planet like the first one I also
built a base fit with the teleporter so
I could easily get back to it if I found
another planet that had equals
survivability and benefits and it's like
I became this intergalactic mining
extraordinaire with houses on several
planets a significant amount of money
that I was making by mining and refining
and then selling rare resources I didn't
need and an efficiency for minimizing
time on dangerous planets outside of
landing scanning for resources that
might be valuable for me to sell and new
life-forms or you know as much
exploration as satisfied my curiosity so
you're combining space exploration which
is amazing in itself with much more
ongoing personal decisions and as a
result it feels fulfilling in ways that
it just didn't back at launch speaking
of which I think I just personally enjoy
it so much more on survival mode because
the stakes are higher and I say that as
someone who generally does really enjoy
challenging games there's totally a
chance that you'd prefer normal mode if
you don't want that increased risk of
death and the ability to lose all of
your items but I still find normal mode
a little too simple it's definitely
chill they're right about that but I
think because of the lack of challenge
and the game still is procedurally
generated sometimes things feel very
lifeless sometimes some planets you come
across ah uninteresting even though
that's a lot less frequent that it
wasn't launched and I think that just
because of that without a little more
challenge I don't feel like I'm
accomplishing enough for it to really
grab me even if there is far more to do
and far more direct
then when the game first came out also
there's a permadeath mode too if you're
into that it combines the difficulty of
survival mode with you know permanent
death there's also a creative mode where
you completely can't die and you have
unlimited resources which is great for
building and learning to build which I
will add I did a lot of in survival mode
on the Xbox one and ps4 I'm not sure
about PC building actual structures is a
little awkward in that sometimes it's
hard to direct where exactly you want to
put a certain thing but it's effectively
required if you want to hide yourself
from extreme weather storms and it's
convenient to have a structure that you
know houses a lot of the items you only
to survive you can even build farms
things what we replenish your oxygen or
your sodium or even literally farm them
like a device that generates oxygen as
you get later into the progression
system there's enough variety and things
to build it it also just feels like
you're always learning always
discovering new things always on the
heels of the next cool device you'll be
able to craft and then you can approach
finding the materials at your own pace
crafting adds an extra objective for you
to piss you on top of already trying to
upgrade or get new ships or vehicles or
mining wear items to sell on the
Galactic market or taking jobs to make
money or discover new planets or
whatever else the options are that
finally exists in no man's sky now my
biggest complaint I think is that mining
can feel pretty repetitive there are
only so many times I can know that I
need to mine rocks before I start going
okay let's go find some more rocks I
guess almost all of your equipment is
upgradeable so you can make that system
faster and more efficient but you still
are spending a lot of time mining and
without the luxury of coming across
underground mine shops or what have you
it loses its appeal a much miner get it
minor complaint is that some items
require really specific aiming like
you'll think you're looking right at it
but you won't be prompted to pick it up
or it can't be mined that's an annoying
one because there's no way to really
learn what's correct sometimes it works
sometimes it just doesn't and when
you're mining for a long time that gets
annoying the UI specifically the menu
can also feel a little bit cluttered
when your inventory is full there's a
lot of information on screen and often
the easiest way to find the recipe you
might need to build something is to find
it in your inventory which can feel like
an unnecessary multi-step process I also
need to mention that I encountered
frequent framerate drops on both Xbox
one and ps4 but I did not encounter any
major bugs or crashes or any save file
issues like a lot of other people have
fortunately but apparently all of these
issues are being patched up a cool stuff
that you might care about that I feel
like I'm running out of time to talk
about you can fight pirate so basically
be a pirate and dogfight space battles
and upgrade for combat orientated ships
if that's what you're about I tended to
avoid pretty much all that you can build
up a fleet of ships and send them on
missions for you all the while building
up your own captain ship to
progressively get cooler and cooler
there's a basic character customisation
system if you really want to change your
avatar including it down to species and
the designs are all surprisingly really
different and creative honestly in 2018
there's just so much stuff to do in no
man's sky and I thoroughly enjoy all of
the stuff I'm choosing to do and that's
the beauty of it there's a lot of
variety so finding what works for you
give it a shot
I'm not saying everyone's going to like
the game because it's never going to be
for everyone of course I'm not going to
forgive all of the failures and I don't
think the industry will forget how that
all went down and it was very ugly for
everyone involved but hey I'm glad they
spent so much time walking on it so I
get spend so much time playing it for
what it is today
with that everyone let me know if you
have any more questions let me know if
you've been playing it I would love to
hear what you guys think you know
especially considering most people
including myself were negative on it
when it first came out it's just a
fascinating journey and yeah I'm Alana
and I will see you guys next time